Facebook's declare is putting a ban on
any materials promoting white separatism
and white nationalism on its platform
we're announcing a ban on praise support
and representation of white nationalism
and white separatism on Facebook and
Instagram it's clear these concepts are
deeply linked to organized hate groups
and have no place on our services these
new rules then come in next week and
they're aimed at as Facebook says taking
a stand against hate this month the
social media giant came under intense
criticism for its role of the spread of
violent content online over how it
handled that video of the Christ Church
mosque shooting in New Zealand the
gunman live-streamed his deadly rampage
and published a white nationalist
manifesto online but critics still argue
Facebook is just skirting around the
issues of radicalism and discrimination
it's absolutely right that white
supremacists
and racist ideology is also confronted
and I welcome it but it's far too late
for those of us campaigning against
racism who've been calling for this
action for many years it's taken a
massacre in New Zealand of Muslims to
actually get Facebook to face up to
their responsibilities this is not our
erosion of free speech this is a private
company platform media platform where
you have to sign up to terms of
conditions and if you breach them then
you will be held responsible for that
I'll remove from that platform I get
that Facebook is a private company and I
get that you have an agreement between
yourself and Facebook and you don't
necessarily have a right to be on
Facebook but obviously these are social
media giants are so huge and so dominant
that clearly we do have to take a
concern and a thought for what they get
up to and it always seems with Facebook
they are the last to act the bigger
principle is here is that you've got to
tackle hate and you've got to be able to
have responsible conversations it's when
it crosses over to demonizing and hating
a whole community that is the issue and
Facebook I've always supported for many
years but internationally I've looked at
what more support we can give to the
authorities to police these social media
giants because they are you
multi-billionaire companies we've really
tried to stop them spreading Islamist
propaganda and Facebook to be fed took
some action but only after a huge amount
of pressure and I think one of the other
concerns I've got about these social
media platforms is to what extent all
the people get dragged along with it and
so the concern is you know firstly are
they getting the balance right but also
the other thing that we've got to say
time and time again is why the heck are
we dragging these social media platforms
kicking and screaming into doing their
duty I mean a massacre in Christchurch
streamed live on social media is that
the level we've got - it's your platform
and you're responsible for where he's
been hosted on that and I think the idea
that self-regulation of these platforms
is something which the British
government for example have been pushing
for a number of years just doesn't work
we missed as well it's got to be tackle
it's got to be confronted and it's got
to be eradicated
you